If I have an MRI with contrast, what do I take to get rid of the contrast?
So the contrast used with MRIs is typically gadolidium.
So gadolidium is technically a heavy metal and so how do you get rid of that?
Well, your body is detoxy, so your body is constantly trying to detox.
So the more you can support your detoxification pathways using support of your liver, using
coffee enemas, using hot packs over your liver, you're going to help detox that.
We do have an MRI homeopath, a gadolidium homeopath on our store that you could use to help
pull that out as well.
Is it necessary for everybody to take the gadolidium homeopath if they're going to do an MRI
with contrast?
No, it's not necessary.
It's just another precaution.
But you know, anything you are doing to detoxify is going to help detoxify.
gadolidium is detoxed through the liver phase one, phase two pathways like any other toxic.
So, but if you're interested in something specific for that, you could call our store
and ask Megan about the gadolidium homeopath there.
You could look up the store MRI detox MRI homeopath and you'll see that available.